about a video that i did about six
months ago called
seven ways to network better so i looked
at the video it's doing pretty well
check it out on youtube valuetainment
economics seven ways to network better i
wanted to bring up some of the key
points get your guys perspective and see
if it still ranks true six months later
why would it not but again six months
ago there weren't in-person meetings
right so can we do this quick rundown
real quick what are your thoughts
marcelo oh there it is
already implementing that makes sense
thank you
go for it so number one
of the seven ways to network better
there's a lot of don'ts in here things
to don't do
number one was don't show up blind what
does that mean
a lot of these
meetings or conferences will have an
agenda or a pre-attendee list is what
it's called basically who's going to be
registered to show up who's going to be
there and the number one thing that you
should understand is
from that list
i have to meet these three people
there's gonna be a thousand people at
this conference these are my main
targets to meet right
a lot of these conferences some day
sometimes it's one day sometimes it's
three days very rarely is it longer than
that but there's gonna be a
thousand people there sometimes it's
more sometimes it's less make a list of
who you want to see and meet those
people so that's number one don't show
up blind now if there's no attendee list
maybe that means showing up and seeing
what's the schedule looking like because
sometimes you can just show up like i
don't know what's going on you're just
kind of
lost at these meetings with this
conference but you can show up go on the
website go on the app and say all right
this is the schedule this is going to be
there go in with the game plan as always
the game plan is always a good thing
that's number one i also think that
these are seven things that not only
help you network better but just help
you have better relationships in general
like i think like no matter what you're
doing whether because maybe not a lot of
people are going to networking events
but they're going anywhere they're going
to a job interview they're going to a
business meeting they're going to you
know
meet somebody that could potentially
give them a job in the future like all
these things weren't true for anything
that you're pulling up to
you brought up a good point not a lot of
people go to networking events right and
my response to that is why not
no matter what field you're in you could
still go to networking events business
meetings conferences
come to the vault sure give a level
how much do i actually give a give
a level what story was that uh
we talked about that what's your give a
level i think two weeks ago oh ways
to become a top performer yes do you
give a that's probably the most
important man i don't give a all
right well clearly you're not gonna
perform well thank you david you're on
point that coffee number two
don't show up late
okay
this ain't a party all right it's
sometimes it's cool
the party starts at nine strolling at 9
45 10 you go you know you're with a
couple friends you show up late that's
kind of cool fashionably late you know
party starts at nine you're there at 8
45 it's like dude like how eager are you
to be here it's kind of how we roll with
this podcast absolutely late sure i'm
passionately late exactly but to these
conferences especially if it's the
conference is from
noon to five o'clock today get your ass
there at noon right like don't be late
don't show up fast relate to a business
conference it's like a business meeting
if you have a business meeting you show
up on time there's nothing fashionable
about being late to business not late to
business zero what are your thoughts
marcelo
don't be late dude ah what is it um
there's there's a weird
feeling you get when you are late
like you just feel inferior
like you walk in there and everybody's
there earlier than you and they look at
you they look down on you right it's
like this energy it's like oh this look
at this poor kid you always make all the
noise
he doesn't have his life together
excuse me i'm sorry keep going
that's where you that's where you start
to throw excuses it's just it looks weak
upon you let me tell you something and
i'm someone who is notorious for running
a little bit late we run five minutes
late for this podcast today for business
meetings i show up again i was in
orlando for
three days the conference started monday
when did i show up sunday night checked
into the hotel ready to go
just a little perspective for you by the
way
the people watching we are ready at 4pm
we're all sitting and we all decide to
be a little late just for just to think
of fashion oh well just make them wait
fashionably late thank you david for
that go ahead number three
don't be sloppy
this to me
i don't know if it's the most important
but it's high up there i just came from
this meeting and there was a group of
men speaking
uh with a with another man oh
and
the man was giving the presentation and
the other group of men
i know that they were thinking the whole
time dude you gotta lose like 100 pounds
the guy was 500 pounds slop he was a
mess
but not only was he physically his shirt
was untalked just didn't look good i
told the story about this some guy
showed up in a meeting i swear to god on
my life with about a pound of ear hair
coming out of his ear like did you not
look in the mirror sergey
sergey
come correct look in the mirror yeah i
don't care if you're in shape out of
shape you could still look good that's
what i'm gonna say you can be a cleaned
up fat guy exactly you can totally be we
have friends here that are cleaned up
fat guys they look good i'm just kidding
marcelo i know you're a fashionable guy
you don't show up too fashionably late
you're not sloppy what are your thoughts
on this one um
as you know my mom would say represent
the family
so
represent your family don't embarrass
the fans you go out there and embarrass
me out there marcelo embarrass me so
don't embarrass yourself i think there's
a big especially nowadays
dude you gotta smell good you gotta like
there's no excuse bro there's so many
products you can use you got to smell
good you got to look decent it all goes
back to your give a level give a
you actually give a about how
you're viewed don't be sloppy now number
four
is something that i know for a fact
david marcelo myself do not have a
problem with number four is don't be shy
don't be shy
introduce yourself give a firm handshake
say what's up crack a joke if you need
to to ingratiate the audience a little
bit be
memorable nobody likes a wall flower
unless you're like the smartest guy in
the room and it's like all right just
give him the reports he'll deal with it
later but don't be shy at a networking
event don't be shy yeah that's the whole
point of the networking yes is to uh
network like if you go there and you're
shy and you're it's a two-day conference
and you spend 48 hours there you meet
zero people and you got zero business
cards if you transacted zero business
because you were afraid to get out of
your comfort zone aka your comfort zone
will kill you
you're dead in business yeah exactly
yeah don't be shy a hundred percent i
agree thank you sir you're not a shy guy
were you ever shy
um i am a little bit shy on the inside
definitely i don't like it yeah i always
get nervous when i have to talk to
people but i have found that
if you are shy that moment when like you
break out mm-hmm it's awesome like you
kind of it's a it's a good moment also
people people like it when you take your
opportunities like if you think about
all these rappers all these hustlers
like they freestyle in front of the guy
when he's walking to his car there was a
guy that freestyled in front of drake
like on that while drake was getting
into his car and yeah he got to know him
like there's a lot of moments like that
in history that you're like dude you
just gotta do you just gotta do it yeah
because worst case scenario drake just
drives away best case scenario he's like
yo that was sick uh here's the whatever
right so there's a lot of risk rewards
i'm an extrovert you're an extrovert you
i would say are an extrovert with some
tendencies to be shy is what you're
saying sure so you know half of people
are extroverts however introverts so
here's my advice to the introverts out
there because the extroverts they're
going to be okay
introverts
okay take a deep breath
i know you're scared i know it's not
what you want to do but think of the big
picture is it better for you to get out
there shake some hands you know make
your rounds at these meetings and get
some business done or is it easier for
your ego and for your comfort level to
be shy and not really you know meet
people i think you know the answer to
that so sometimes introverts can
you know
have very productive careers in what
they do right but sometimes you got to
get out of your comfort zone your
comfort zone will kill you so that's
advice to the
introverts and maybe even plan it
whenever i'm really nervous whenever i'm
feeling shy and i have to talk to
somebody that i think is kind of out of
my league i plan something to say i go
i'm going to bring this up and then
that's then i'm going to be safe go in
with the gameplay go in with the game
don't show up blind
boom
david that cup of coffee is waking you
up i love it number five
this is for the selfish people out there
this is for the people that want to make
it all about themselves number five
don't make it all about you
at a networking meeting you're there to
meet people to hear their story right
you're not there to tell your story to
everybody okay make it about them we
always talk about this the best sales
thing you could do not telling selling
isn't telling selling is
asking ask questions and you know what
you do after you ask the question shut
up
and listen
listen to their answer okay that makes
sense now i was wondering well well you
said you said you said that's very you
said that you didn't want to spend that
on this so here's my suggestion you had
mentioned that oh this guy is actually
listening holy moly so don't make it
about you marcelo
i don't want to make this about me i
don't want to make this a i want to make
this about you
what are your thoughts
i think it makes you notice a theme here
it makes sense
people like to talk about themselves it
totally makes sense if you're ever
talking about somebody that's bigger
than you or they're you know in a in a
higher place and you know if you just
talk about yourself the whole time
they're like this isn't that interesting
i'm actually doing really interesting
things maybe you should ask about me or
it's like someone who says
shaq tomorrow yeah i probably wouldn't
tell him about me too much i probably
would ask him some questions about him
well played yeah and i think i mean
that's a great approach to meeting
anyone i mean that's what i do is i just
ask
what you said is 100 true you just ask
because
who doesn't like talking about
themselves right they they want to talk
you just allow the horse and then you
become more of a mystery because they
know everything about me i know nothing
about that and then they ask you and now
you're in a conversation are you in a
conversation you both care so a part of
that you ever dealt with this person
who's like the one upper
yeah so david i just got back from new
york yeah i'm from new york yeah where
were you oh i was in the bro i'm from
the bronx what did you like it's like
dude
i'm telling you my story here i don't
need you to one up
right i went to the heat kim i was at
the heat game too
thanks bro
telling my personal story here so don't
make it about you i played for the heat
i play for the heat he players slept on
my couch
number six
don't be an amateur this is an amateur
hour over here even if you've been there
for a week or a month or it's your first
year in the business act like you know
what you're doing okay know your stuff
at the very least have an elevator pitch
you know how he said
don't make it about you in number five
number six
make it about you that you at least you
know your stuff in this regard elevator
pitch tell me what you do in like 30
seconds or less boom spit it out yeah or
or whatever the most interesting thing
about you is like you got to have that
on hand like whenever you meet people
you got to be like all right this is
what's going to be interesting to you
like i'm sure when you talk to somebody
they go oh what do you do saznik you go
oh i do this podcast i also work in
insurance i do this and i do that
you have to have a quick way to say what
you do because you're not going to be
able to talk for a long time and then
have them stay in it you got to have
what you do what do you do you gotta
have a question you gotta have it you
gotta have an answer for that you gotta
be a hook too gotta be a hook listen to
your corner and watch out for the hook
number seven
don't blow it in the end what does that
mean you know how we talked about don't
be late this is kind of the this is kind
of like the antithesis of that is stay
late
you're at a business conference
okay
the conference ends at five don't cut
out at 4 30.
stay late what i love doing is doing a
final lap
love doing a final lap anywhere anywhere
parties final lap i get an irish goodbye
some people want to do that before the
irish goodbye do a final lap is there
someone i can meet just something i
could do
is there some person that i somehow
missed um
very important to do 100 the guard goes
down
once the party's kind of dwindling
everybody's guard comes down you know
what i mean you go to the host of the
party yeah hey man great party and they
go you know what thank you thank you hey
by the way to head out but i just wanted
or not even that are they go you know
what we're actually going to head to
this after party exactly or we're going
to or you know what
me and my wife we've been dying to you
know talk to you about this or me and my
girl
i'm telling you a lot of times it
happens you stay a little bit late i
would stay late at comedy shows all the
time all the time and that's how at the
end of the comedy show once everybody
leaves and you're hanging out with the
producer he goes hey man do you want to
do the show sometime bingo do you want
to go do you want to come on next week
it's like those
also do you know why staying late works
mm-hmm shows you care you never stay
late on something you don't care about
give a level like give a level
just through the roof if you stay late
yeah anyway those are seven things that
you can do better to network better in
person meetings are back it's official
without a whistle and this is actually
happening so hopefully
you take something from this
for me
don't be shy don't be sloppy
don't be shy
don't make it about yourself know your
we all owned it up
um here's the final takeaway those are
the seven things
so
like we said on the video networking is
where the conversation begins not where
it ends so after the networking event
there's two words that you have to do
follow up follow up you can get all you
can have the best meeting in the world
have a great time make all these
contacts and then you don't follow up
with any of them how the hell's business
going to get done right what's everyone
gives business cards these days
obviously where people these days will
take a picture on the phone and all that
fancy stuff follow up
great book how to win friends and
influence people you got to care about
people you know they always say no
matter what business you're in you're in
the people business and these are seven
ways to get better with your people you
know they always say marcelo your net
work is your net worth if you add up the
five people you associate with the most
that's who you are so who you rolling
with is money all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay
[Music]
broken money